con la esperanza puesta en las vacunas y
preocupación por la creciente presencia
de las nuevas variantes del virus los
líderes de la unión europea se reunieron
para debatir medidas en la cumbre se
acordó impulsar la rápida distribución
de las vacunas y mejorar los esfuerzos
para un rastreo eficaz
úrsula von der leyen presidenta de la
comisión europea dijo que los viajes no
esenciales están altamente
desaconsejados y anunció recomendaciones
para los países considerados de alto
riesgo
proponemos introducir una nueva
categoría de rojo oscuro que muestra que
en las zonas que lo tienen el virus está
circulando en un nivel muy alto las
personas que viajen de zonas rojo oscuro
podrían ser obligadas a hacerse una
prueba antes de su partida así como
realizar cuarentena a su llegada todo
esto dentro de la unión europea
after dry bolt kim hyunjoon la situación
epidemiológica de europa no es
prometedora portugal decidió cerrar
todos los colegios del país y suspender
los vuelos con el reino unido- a partir
del sábado en francia el gobierno
decidió mantener el toque de queda a las
6 de la noche y exigir pruebas pcr a
viajeros europeos que lleguen al país
por vía aérea no se descarta un tercer
confinamiento nacional si tenemos que
hacerlo porque estamos rastreando esta
nueva variante británica en todos los
sitios que es detectada si vemos que ha
habido un aumento masivo en casos y eso
está conllevando una ola epidémica y nos
encontramos en la misma situación que
nuestros vecinos en las semanas pasadas
podríamos imponer otras medidas que
incluyen el confinamiento reino unido-
ya no hace parte de la unión pero el
virus no respeta fronteras allí el
gobierno amenazó a los ciudadanos que no
cumplieran con las restricciones con
sanciones económicas